[Applaudissements]
finalement nous apprendre beaucoup plus
et ben c'est bien c'est christine
kristin effet à l'école ce que je veux
faire une interview sous les jupons de
la télévision la coop ce que vous faites
sous les chauds pour l'histoire donc
sans langue de bois vous nous répondez
on sait que vous répondez toujours
connaissez selon vous quelle animatrice
a le plus le melon le melon nombre et où
d'une ancienne scène vraiment kissed a
raconté pourquoi une animatrice ou alors
un animateur negi un extrait bien
d'accord votre père expérience à
l'aplomb temps est passé sous votre
votre pire et c'est mon idole voilà il
est très bon animateur mais vous trouvez
qu'il a le melon jemaye où l'on
rencontre souvent vous en vouliez un
illettré il est plutôt sympathique votre
pays et ce car le lui vous êtes vraiment
un peu faux cul cherche à banaliser
je vous adore je vous aide et nagui et
moi dans la guide nagui on n en a qui on
s'entend bien à guy moi il y en a
d'autres qui je m'entends moi bien oui
la guerre on s'entend bien vous savoir
une chose toi même c'est que hier sur
twitter avant de venir ici
christine bravo a quand même demandé à
ses à ses followers qu'albanel ce quelle
méchanceté est pouvait vous balancer un
mais alors il ya elle en a reçu plein
oui bah là et regarder ce qu'elle a
envoyée après comme tenue pour les rien
je suis plié de rire à cause de vos
méchanceté pour cyril hanouna mais je
suis plus tout jeune on sait pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonne chance à lui envoyer vous aviez
nobody ni plus sympa que vous non on m'a
demandé de dire mais c'est vraiment mais
je ne fais pas tous en même temps c'est
que c'est quand même la seule au monde
qui pense que sur twitter ça peut être
discret votre pire expérience à la
télévision c'était quoi c'était frédéric
mitterrand a way qui mangeaient le micro
et qui est qui qui voulait absolument
pas que je parle jamais à wes jameer et
c'était ma première émission en direct
staff
j'avais une choucroute staff vous dites
ça pourrait n'aura pas c'est parce qu'il
va le mieux à tes jolies mais on est
comme ça tu aimes pas ça mais non mais
c'est pas rock band vous faire un peu
vous pensez que ça marche encore de
coucher pour réussir mais moi j'ai moi
j'ai réussi pour coucher
[Rires]
probablement alors vous pensez quoi de
la direction de france télévisions
aujourd'hui je ne connais pas d'accord
ce que je sais c'est que le projet sous
les jupons de l'histoire c'était pas
assez bien pour eux d'accord mais c'est
quoi le plus gros défaut de laurent
ruquier une mauvaise foi méchant à mieux
non
ainsi si il me lâche pas d'une semelle
il est tout le temps derrière moi à me
dire fais pas ci fais pas ça il est
comme moi en fait un nom c'est juste
insupportable défensive et un générateur
famille ça rien à voir et surtout pas
libéré un mois au moins vous gardé un
bon souvenir de votre collaboration avec
christophe dechavanne
non non c'est pas possible je l'ait
quittée en plaquant la porte parce que
ça il était bas voilà il était de
chavannes
il voit là on s'entendait pas il était
un peu comme moi aussi vous avez aussi
que la bourre avec cauet mais maintenant
c'est à lui qu est très intéressant
parce que humainement formidable mon
père était malheureusement très malade
et et il est mort pendant que je
tournais ses émissions il a été
exceptionnel humainement maintenant
professionnellement tout ce que j'ai dit
la coupée au montage avec beaugrand
c'est à dire que je pense que il dit
c'est pas un type de bande qui peut
mettre en valeur comme vous le faites
comme laurent le fait est généreux avec
des chroniqueurs je pense que il est
trop lui même mais il est excellent
c'est un très bon animateur je pense
qu'il n'a pas besoin de chroniqueurs il
n'avait pas besoin de moi ni de bogrand
vous dire nous on prend des chroniqueurs
parce que tout seul on est très mauvais
c'est pourtant avec un de mes relais de
générosité vous parler d'argent ou ou
d'autres choses d'argent aussi ah bon ah
oui alors on va avec avec moi oui non
vous avez une fausse idée sam de cette
émission aurait dix ans a dit plusieurs
fois que vous aviez chopé le melon qui
ardisson il a distancé
kerry mais qui sait
même le roquefort qui dit au camembert
tu pues ardisson qui dit que j'ai le
melon bas ils ont regardé le être enfin
alors lui mais je les aime bien ouais
c'est ça vous voulez je l'aimé bien
je retombe dans le panneau des kim prend
dans ses bras sans habit rouge et ça me
remet à 18 ans parce que quand way à
bisous parfois vous sentez parfois et ça
y est vous réconcilier avec quelqu'un
christophe savez pareil c'est christophe
dechavanne ils me voient comme parfois
christophe dechavanne à des rouges
d'accord mais nous avions d'abord on
voit très bien christine bravo et année
[Applaudissements]